and welcome to hannity and tonight the
constant assault on your freedom from
the self-serving politicians in the
washington dc swamp is unyielding with
the help of a few weak need republicans
a brand new gun control bill just
advanced on capitol hill we'll do
nothing for gun safety in schools we'll
explain
senator cruz he opposes this legislation
will be here to respond that's coming up
also we'll have more on the biden's
administration's and their plan to ban
juul
tobacco products and take nicotine out
of cigarettes all while your government
is legalizing weed and in other places
hard drugs does it make any sense
government makes a fortune on taxing
tobacco over 12 billion dollars a year
why would they want to give that up
anyway we begin tonight though with
biden's war on your ability to live your
life without going bankrupt now between
inflation spiking gas prices record
prices a looming recession americans are
suffering and it's about to get a whole
lot worse according to one washington
post columnist and on msdnc you all need
to stop complaining and be grateful that
joe biden is your president okay
i'm just gonna say this and and and if i
get bang for it i don't care there are
there's a great deal of americans where
it is uncomfortable that they're
spending more but they are not going to
go under you know you you got to stop
complaining when there's so many people
who literally the inflation rate means
they may only have two meals instead of
three so i'm gonna need you to calm down
and back off because it feeds into this
fear and then this fear feeds into
people making decisions that creates the
very thing that they're fearful of and
if you're in that category
calm down stop looking at your portfolio
calm down back off stop looking at your
portfolio even though two-thirds of
americans are now living paycheck to
paycheck because of biden economic and
energy policies that build back better
turned into settle for less and shut
your mouth pretty quickly la times
meanwhile has a slightly different take
look at the headline quote yes a
recession looks inevitable but it may
not be that bad
okay now the article then goes on to
explain that it was just a normal part
of american economic life no it's not in
reality this looming recession coupled
with massive inflation coupled with
record high gas prices this is a
disaster that is impacting especially
the poor the middle class and people on
fixed incomes we have not seen this
since oh the jimmy carter years but
don't worry because biden just
introduced his big new plan he's going
to save everyone 18 cents on every
gallon of gasoline you buy a brand new
temporary god forbid forever cancelled
gas tax holiday as they call it and
according to joe he's doing everything
humanly possible everything possible
within his power to bring prices down he
is trying real hard
i promise you i'm doing everything
possible
everything possible to bring the price
of energy down gas prices down
i want to make sure we all work on this
together
everything humanly possible except
create more supply with drilling permits
except restarting the keystone xl
pipeline we'd be getting 900 000 barrels
of canadian oil a day if we had finished
it except lifting the ban on exploration
in anwar other federal lands
except let's see getting refineries back
online come to think of it biden has
already done everything humanly possible
to drive up the price at the pump drive
up inflation artificially reduce the
world's supply of the lifeblood of the
world's economy that's oil and gas just
like he told us he would do over and
over and over again he's doing exactly
what he said he would do when he was
running in 2020. i'll remind you take a
look
we're all dead doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them liable
for what they have done particularly in
those cases where your underserved
neighborhoods and you you know the deal
okay and by the way when they don't or
when they're deliberate put them in jail
kiddo
i want you to just take a look okay you
don't have to agree but i want you to
look in my eyes
i guarantee you i guarantee you we're
going to end fossil fuel and i am not
going to cooperate okay would there be
any place for fossil fuels including
coal and fracking in the biden
administration
no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated
eliminated we would work it out you get
the deal you get the deal for god's
sakes i'm doing what i said i do anyway
as for the gas tax holiday almost
everyone in the democratic party
including barack obama and even nancy
pelosi they have already referred to
this as a political gimmick which it is
i'll take the twenty dollars over the
summer that it'll save me but it does
nothing to improve the lives of you the
american people take a look
and we're arguing over a gimmick to save
you half a tank of gas
over the course of the entire summer so
that everyone in washington can pat
themselves on the back and say that they
did something president biden is is
thinking about implementing the federal
gas tax holiday i mean that temporarily
suspend uh the 18.3 cent per gallon tax
on gas do you do you think that that
would actually help or is it more of a
stunt
it's it's look i mean i'm i'm very
sympathetic to the administration
wanting to be seen doing something but
it is pretty much a stunt i'm no fan of
the gas tax uh holiday i think that's
kind of a gimmick and eventually you
have to uh reverse it the pro is very
showbiz okay let's just do something
there it is but it is not necessarily
landing in the pocket of the consumer
it's taken out of the trust fund we have
to pay for that to return it
kamal is second she's first in line to
be president if anything god forbid ever
happened to joe and that one second
anyway even official officials in
biden's own administration they can't
get on the same page with this gas tax
holiday take a look at this montage put
together by townhall.com take a look at
this
what do you say to lawmakers who are
already calling this federal gas tax
holiday a gimmick and saying best case
scenario it'll save drivers about 20
bucks a month well it there's no doubt
this is a modest if it were just the
federal gas tax right 18 cents is
you know is a modest uh you know modest
amount we're talking about uh you know
18 cents uh per gallon which is going to
go a long way if you look at the average
of states that's 30 cents just looking
at those two things that's almost 50
cents
that's going to go a long way for three
months
it's going to go a long way that's the
same person that actually said
it was very windy the day that joe
tripped three times going up the stairs
to air force one and the same person
that said i have a hard time keeping up
with joe wow here's the truth if you
drive a small to mid-size suv seven
several thousand miles this summer your
gas savings from this gimmick would be
around 20 bucks i'll take the 20 bucks
not exactly life-changing though and i
guess it's slightly better than biden's
last plan of action which was to do
absolutely nothing and blame trump and
vladimir putin and fox news and oil
companies in fact the administration
they have blamed putin for absolutely
everything inflation gas prices we've
shown you the charts you know it's a lie
apparently according to the white house
though putin has a much greater
influence over the economy than joe
biden your president now of course that
is all nonsense simply it's a flat out
lie and today fed chairman jerome powell
well he completely obliterated biden's
favorite talking point take a look
given how inflation has escalated over
the past 18 months
would you say that the word ukraine is
the primary driver of inflation in
america
no inflation was high before certainly
before the
war in ukraine broke out i'm glad to
hear you say that the biden
administration seems to be intent on
deflecting blame and as recently as just
this past sunday spread the
misinformation that putin's invasion of
ukraine is the quote biggest single
driver of inflation i'm glad you agree
with me that that is not the truth
yeah it's at a record 8.6 the highest in
40 years cpi and uh only 1.4 since
vladimir invaded ukraine so it wasn't
vladimir that caused america's inflation
like his energy policies uh that wasn't
caused by putin either high gas prices
putin didn't pump two trillion dollars
into an already hot u.s economy joe
biden did putin didn't artificially
reduce america's domestic production of
oil and gas joe biden did putin didn't
let sociology majors stop paying their
graduate degree loans joe biden that was
his gift with our money now frankly i'm
sick and tired i'm sure you are too of
joe biden refusing to ever take any
responsibility for anything he does but
what should we expect from our long-time
lying corrupt and dishonest president
you know the guy that uses crack
addicted son to make a buck and lied
about having any knowledge about his
foreign business dealings uh who let his
son pay his bills a guy that's been
lying and cheating and plagiarizing his
way through life from law school to the
white house a guy who spends half the
week on vacation in delaware but tonight
despite all of this there is at least
one person who must be happy somewhere
in america jimmy carter wherever you are
is probably smiling thanks to joe he is
no longer the worst president uh in
modern american history hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else